RUSSELL WESTBROOK.
QUICK TO THE BASKET.
FOR A HIM.K.
DOWN DEEP, ANTHONY DAVE FACE AH.
HE IS MOVING WITHEIGHT, RIGHT N
DOWN BRADLEY, ANOTHER BLOCK BY
CLIPPERS?RTER FOR RUSSELL THE L
ONE OF NEW  ATART LIKE DUARTE
HAS.
>> Chris: RED-HOTIN.
THAT'S WHAT THEY CALL THE
BAILOUT. MY JUST
>> HE WAS THERE. TO
SUSAN CATCHES. THEY HIM UNDER
THE BASKET.
>> THROW DOWN. THAT'S THE
WAY YOU ATTACK. S. RUSS GOES IN
THE LAKERS A FOUR-POINT LEAD
THEIR ACTION. ROSS TO AD FLIES
TO THE RIM. CK TO GOGO
OPPORTUNITY. SO THE LAKERSY
HELP. RUSS RUSS HAS A TRIPLE
DOUBLE.
>> ICING ON
>> LOB TO AD. HE'S GOT IT AND
FOUR-POINT GAME SUCCESSFUL AS
BUDDY
MOMENTS. I KNOW IT'S MAYBE
YOUR FAVORITE MOMENTS RIGHT
THERE. ONE OF THEM.
>> RUSS, ALL THE WAY. LAY IT
UP. AND IN HE CROSSED OVER ON
CADE
>> OUT FOR RUSS RUSS IN ATTACK
MODE, ALWAYS ALWAYS. AND TO
H T
PASS AFTER THE GAME WILL GO
STRAIGHT
TRANSITION.
THIS IS A GAME OF RUNS, WE'RE
OUT-OF-BOUNDS.
>> Kayte: RUSSELL WESTBROOK
RIGH
WESTBROOK IN THE FRONTCOURT INP
NOW.
DAVIS CALLING FOR ITEY'RE GOINGS
AS THE GAME GOES ALONG.
YOU SEE ON THE SHOT
CLOCK, OVERTIVE
PASSES. HE TAPS IT AHEAD. AND
LEBRON WITH THE E RUSS INTO THE
>> ON THE NIGHT SPLITTING THE
DEFENSE
>> LAY IT UP. A A WITH THE LAKE
DEFENSE.
THEY HAVE BEEN GREAT TONIGHT.
>> Stan: RUSSELL WESTBROOK HERE,
OFF OF THE MISSED FREE THROW. WE
AGGRESSIVE THAT TIME AND TATUM
DID NOT HOLD